lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
usar lo que sabemos sobre los polinomios
y cómo manipularlos y lo que hemos
hablado acerca de si dos polinomios son
iguales entre sí para todos los valores
de la variable en la que están escritos
si es que estamos tratando con una
identidad polinomiales y vamos a usar
esas habilidades para demostrar algunas
propiedades de las relaciones entre los
números así que si tuviera que enumerar
algunos enteros podría decir 0 1 2 3 4 5
y si tuviera que enumerar los cuadrados
de estos números crear una sucesión de
cuadrados enteros
bueno 0 al cuadrado es igual a 0 1 al
cuadrado es 1 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 al
cuadrado es 9 4 al cuadrado es 16 5 al
cuadrado es 25 y por supuesto podríamos
seguir adelante en cualquier caso pero
lo primero en lo que quiero que pienses
antes de que incluso escriba un
polinomio o intente construir uno es
mirar esta sucesión de enteros cuadrados
puedes ver algún patrón en términos de
la diferencia entre los términos de esta
sucesión de enteros cuadrados muy bien
pensemos en esto juntos para ir de 0 a 1
sumamos 1 para ir de 14 sumamos 3 para
pasar de 49 sumamos 5 para pasar de 9 a
16 sumamos 7 parece que aquí hay un
patrón a medida que avanzamos hacia los
términos sucesivos de esta sucesión de
enteros cuadrados estamos sumando
números impares crecientes entonces
supongo que si sumó 9 aquí que es el
próximo número impar voy a llegar a 25 y
ese es el caso y podrías probar eso
bueno qué pasa si sumo 11
cuál sería el siguiente número que voy a
obtener es 36 que es el cuadrado de 6
pero cómo podemos sentirnos seguros de
que esto siempre sea verdad de que esto
nunca falla bueno una forma de hacerlo
es pensar un poco más en general y ahí
es donde nuestra álgebra y nuestro
conocimiento de los polinomios será útil
así que digamos que vamos hasta el final
y estamos hablando de forma general
tenemos el número n y luego el siguiente
número va a ser n 1 y luego si pensamos
en cuáles serían los términos
correspondientes en la sucesión de los
cuadrados enteros bueno eso sería cuando
lo elevamos al cuadrado cuando lleguemos
a n obtendremos n al cuadrado y cuando
lleguemos a n 1 tendremos n más 1 al
cuadrado y veamos si podemos pensar cuál
es la diferencia entre estas dos cosas
la diferencia entre 25 y 16 69 la
diferencia entre 16 y 97 así que
pensemos en cuál es la diferencia entre
n + 1 al cuadrado y n al cuadrado y como
escribimos eso como un polinomio bueno
solo será n 1 al cuadrado menos n al
cuadrado y ahora veamos si podemos
reescribir esto manipularlo algebraica
mente para que podamos establecer una
identidad polinomio que describa este
patrón que acabamos de ver entonces voy
a resolver n más 1 al cuadrado
así que esto va a ser en el cuadrado más
2 n 1 y luego tenemos este - n al
cuadrado aquí entonces menos n al
cuadrado y así vemos que en el cuadrado
menos en el cuadrado se cancela y
podemos reescribir todo lo que tenemos
aquí como n 1 al cuadrado - n cuadrada
esta es realmente la diferencia entre
los términos sucesivos en nuestra
sucesión de enteros cuadrados que va a
ser igual a 12 n 1 para cualquier n que
sea entero bueno para cualquier entero n
cuanto es 12 n 1 y especialmente aquí
estamos tratando con los enteros
positivos bueno para cualquier entero n
este va a ser un entero impar si tomas
cualquier entero y lo multiplicas por 2
esta parte va a ser par pero luego le
sumas 1 y obtendrás un entero impar y
también puedes ver que esto aumenta en 2
a medida que aumenta entonces cuando
pasas de un entero impar sumas 2 al
siguiente entero impar
2 al siguiente enter impar que es
exactamente lo que se describe aquí eso
está muy bien
acabamos de usar un poco de álgebra un
poco de lo que sabemos sobre las
identidades polinomiales para mostrar
que la diferencia entre los términos
sucesivos en esta sucesión de enteros
cuadrados que tenemos aquí va a ser
igual a un número impar que va a ir
aumentando